when
somebody breaks
your heart
some
somebody
says ready
good morning [ __ ] lickers not my stay
[ __ ] suckers joey coco diaz lisa at the
flying jew the church of what's
happening now is back happy monday
[ __ ] thank you very much for
making a comeback skinny finney's here
going to say hello say hello coxseco
that's right that's right cox i can say
hello again
all right get the [ __ ] out i love you
stay black
what's happening you beautiful
[ __ ] we're here fresh monday
morning positively you want to open that
door and let this pick out before we
step over here smoking dope drinking
green tea [ __ ] bert christian got me
back on again green tea ever since he
got his uh
uh cleansed right so yeah he left like
20 pounds in like a few years yeah no
he's on a [ __ ] roll now he's over in
chicago trip flipping sweating bullets
every time he walks past the hot beef
[ __ ] sandwich because that's what he
really wants you know i'm saying lisa
where the [ __ ] you've been flying around
the city with your little [ __ ]
yamagon cops
i gotta get i gotta get a yummy cup and
slip in the past couple weeks what are
you gonna do brother it's monday it's a
beautiful day to be alive i gotta tell
you something we i went to [ __ ]
minneapolis last week yeah you said it
was amazing you know man uh we live in
california it's beautiful here the sun
the weed and all that [ __ ] but here's
the problem with the midwest that i love
it's the only problem with the milk but
the [ __ ] food is so good and that the
food is so good and i'll tell you what
else you know like from the 30 years of
smoking you know snorting coke and
sniffing [ __ ] and [ __ ] and eating
ass my [ __ ] senses and my nose have
gone away i can't there's times i can
taste food there's times i can't taste
food when you go to the midwest and you
eat like when you eat a steak lee the
[ __ ] steak is a steak
and it tastes like a steak like here in
l.a you go to dantanas you go to a great
steakhouse yeah you pay dollars it's a
[ __ ] great state
in the midwest you get a steak for ten
dollars and it's [ __ ] delicious yeah
they do what you should do you get a
good piece of meat and you put it over
charcoal and that's delicious the
[ __ ] eggs you could taste the eggs in
the [ __ ] like when you bob the egg
yolks were huge they look like big
[ __ ] nipples from the 60s because in
the 60s women had bigger [ __ ] nipples
now they got the little teeny ones there
was like a half a finger it must be
something in the [ __ ] water
but they're [ __ ] huge and you the
butter is richer uh you're just apples
something as simple as [ __ ] apples
here you get like half and half it's
tough to be a fat [ __ ] fruit because
you really can't gauge it sometimes i
buy peaches at night and not peaches but
the things the red ones with a lot of
hair on them whatever the [ __ ] plums
whatever i buy them at night and the
[ __ ] next day from the supermarket
they're [ __ ] bad so you gotta go to
the farmer's market on friday or
something there they were giving away
apples at the hotel that was so
delicious but when i went to do radio
uh the girl at the rate of the tom
bernard show
[ __ ] gave me two different types of
apples from a parent farm and she uh
gave me these apples that
she's like people pay a high dollar fees
wait till you taste this legal
when you bit into it the [ __ ] juice
was everywhere it was sweet it would
drip down your face
like a [ __ ] soldier i mean so it's
just so different you know and i like to
meet people a lot of people in
california be like well i'm from the
east coast and the food sucks here the
foods but i'll tell you what i go to the
east coast and it's a [ __ ] shitty
dude the [ __ ] pieces made by [ __ ]
arabs it's the same [ __ ] [ __ ] and i
got nothing against iron but you
[ __ ] don't make pizza okay and
you go back east and it's the same [ __ ]
and now it's like for me one of the best
places to eat is houston [ __ ] texas
is a fat [ __ ] oh i've never been
oh you have the first of all the
portions [ __ ] kill you there's no
weight watchers in texas they'll kill
those [ __ ] they usually put
weight watchers in texas over all you
could eat chinese restaurant and they
got tons of them down there but the
houston more people go out to dinner in
houston than anywhere else in the
[ __ ] country when you go to houston
you eat you realize why first off you
and your wife could eat for [ __ ] 20
bucks yeah and take two things home with
you you go to [ __ ] houston you got
chewies you got [ __ ] uh carabas with
that and that's the mother based one not
those [ __ ] white satellites they put
all over the country where they ask if
you want manicotti not that [ __ ] i'm
talking about in [ __ ] carabas in
houston they [ __ ] jack you up they
got this uh
blueberry hill i used to call it
blueberry hill berry hill [ __ ]
tamales that's where the rolling stones
get tamales from when the rolling stones
went to houston they [ __ ] went uh
they everybody when you do a show in
local cities all the restaurants get to
bring you food and supposedly barry hill
brought these tamales that's what
[ __ ] zz top used to go through
[ __ ] tremendous they have these
tamales so zz top brought the tamales to
the stones and he was telling me the
story uh the guitar player was telling
me the story el compadre where it all
goes down in hollywood because i had a
hat on one time from barry hill okay and
the guy this is the guitar player from
zz top was that el compadre i was there
doing el campadre is a [ __ ]
restaurant in hollywood but everything
goes down there i seen lindsay lohan
there i've seen a bunch of people down
there if you get what i'm talking about
you follow me
are you kidding me or what they sell i
think they make eight million dollars a
year selling margaritas and 22 million
selling bloat on that they have a little
guitar player that comes by and you
throw like a 20 into a hole in the
guitar and he opens up his arm and a
coke rock falls out
[ __ ] tremendous mexican restaurant i
seen him in there one night
and he seen the hat he told me the story
that he uh when the stones played in
houston he brought him the [ __ ]
tamales and that mick jagger loved him
so much that when they went to australia
berry hill something
the tamale stores because they ship
overnight and when they went to las
vegas uh one year they shipped the
[ __ ] tamales but anyway back to food
it's so weird how
i went to nashville a couple like a
month and a half ago great [ __ ] city
and again i got a slice of pizza lee
that would have [ __ ] killed the horse
it was so delicious in nashville and a
black guy made it and a white wife he
had a white wife he was from buffalo the
[ __ ] pizza was tremendous i had a
what else the oh barbecue of barbecues
you know that's what it was invented in
[ __ ] nashville yeah but it's so weird
now like
i didn't have any i knew that my bro i
was in denver for [ __ ] 15 years in
boulder so i knew that the food was
great but it didn't come along now
there's good food all over this [ __ ]
country but the point of the story being
that the midwest just has that real
it tastes real here i think we get like
the bottom of the [ __ ] barrel like
you guys got weed we'll send you the
shitty [ __ ] meat or whatever i mean
they have to ship it in trucks all the
way from everywhere across the country
because nothing grows here so i mean it
makes it makes sense that we're not
going to get the best quality stuff but
i thought we got like strawberries and
[ __ ] here i mean maybe in northern
california yeah on the way up you see
strawberries and you know cherries and
all that [ __ ] but uh no [ __ ] farms
around here no cows nothing like that
you know i'm scared of [ __ ] animals i
see a cow i run you know that you like
cows how you know i always think that
when i'm around them they're gonna
[ __ ] turn around and just bulldoze me
like one of those matadors and espana
oh my god
what so you like cats we just want like
big animals or is that it or they just
look at you weird give around the
[ __ ] cow how they just look at you
and they eat whatever and you're like
maybe they're thinking about eating my
fat ass dog i'm fat i'm insecure i see
an animal that's bigger than me i don't
need that [ __ ] he's looking at me going
that [ __ ] is a good eat i guess
that was a good either i think i just
haven't been as high around cows as
you've been around cows because you were
looking at a girl and you said that
girl's got good [ __ ] how do you know
you just assumed that guy might look at
us and say that [ __ ] tastes good
you follow me speaking of taste it's
that time lately leland
bang [ __ ] chocolate the church of
what's happening now how you gonna get
up on a monday go out there and tackle
the [ __ ] world ahead of you if you're
not prepared lee you follow me a soldier
don't go out without a [ __ ] gun or a
knife or a bayonet or a [ __ ] dart
something here you go bang chocolate
three strength [ __ ] fire opening up
that's not a banana that's that's that's
the atomic bomb oh stop it looking fun
[ __ ] driving on my bicycle you
following me yeah the last time i saw
you eat that you were saluting clint
eastwood behind you what are you going
to do
what are you going to [ __ ] do that's
the top lord drunky well you gotta
salute him every [ __ ] morning that's
true i don't know who showed up to the
democratic republican convention that
poor guy was all this luck
maybe he's still medical he said i don't
give a [ __ ] bro he went down there he
did what he did he didn't know he was
talking to a puppet
he wasn't he was just a chair it doesn't
matter he did the outlaw josie will yeah
and he did uh dirty harry and jordan
i really enjoyed a bunch of [ __ ]
i really enjoyed last night was funny
because
you know when i travel i can't [ __ ]
fall asleep i can't sleep in those rooms
and my fan broke oh jesus the last night
so i gotta bring a neck and uh the air
conditioner has to be down and then i
gotta bring a fan with me for the
[ __ ] noise and the fan broke saturday
night
so
last night i tried to lay down i got a
little stone you know after i saw you i
tried to work out a little i went for a
walk
and i [ __ ] couldn't sleep that's
halfway that happened a lot and i lost
my mind and i got up and death wish was
just starting on sunday charles bronson
at his best 1971 look
i started watching him eric
go blooms in it okay jeff goldblum plays
one of the muggers i know he wasn't one
of them i didn't know which one but it's
funny how
as a kid i thought they killed his wife
he got a gun and he started shooting
[ __ ] puerto ricans no
it wasn't like that
i seen new york last night
i caught the whole [ __ ] thing i love
to watch a movie and to learn something
especially after i've seen the movie oh
yeah 80 times
after i see a movie 80 times when i
watch a movie and i see something
it [ __ ] blows me the [ __ ] away
and it was so funny because
his wife and his daughter get raped
you know the brother-in-law who's a half
a [ __ ] the son-in-law who's half
[ __ ] calls him up and says hey you
know my mom and uh your daughter got
raped whatever they get to the hospital
the doctor tells him the daughter's okay
but the mother got the mother's dead
child's brother they killed his wife
but i forgot that he went to tucson
to see some dude and the dude was
teaching him how to shoot and [ __ ] and
the duke kept saying dog get out of the
city move down here to tucson but before
he left he put a gun in his suitcase
okay you know he was in tech he was a
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] texas that's
why i love him they don't give a [ __ ] he
snuck a gun on his suitcase
right and when he got to new york he
seen the gun and he goes out the fri and
that's what i caught when he went out
the first night he's standing by the
he's standing in a park i don't know
which park it is
and the guy comes up and give him my
wallet [ __ ] and he shoots that
guy and you see his face when he shoots
him everybody says charles bronson
wasn't a good actor whatever i caught a
lot last night he shoots him and he goes
home and when he gets home he looks at
his hand he's crying he can't believe he
killed somebody i had never thought that
i always thought that he was a killer
from the start they showed him becoming
a killer they showed him hating it and
then enjoying it that's what makes a
good move that's what makes a good
[ __ ] movie they really showed him uh
you know evolving like he goes home
after the first shot and he [ __ ] uh
gets on his hands and knees and he cries
and he can't believe he does it but then
he wants to give it another try he's
like going to jiu jitsu the first time
it's like going to a gym and being a fat
[ __ ]
i don't really like it but i'll come
back until i like it yeah that's where i
mean
coming from now like the take-ins and
all that all those all those movies so
it's interesting to watch the 70s or
whatever let me explain something the
[ __ ] taken somebody did i watched
battleship on the plane out of
oh my screen brother [ __ ] god
oh my god america if you paid and went
to that movie they should beat you
they should [ __ ] beat you for you
[ __ ] idiots oh my god it don't make
sense to me it looked like transformers
but i was like about the battleships
[ __ ] bad bad but the movies have been
horrific this month of september look at
the numbers they're not even telling you
because the movies are so [ __ ] bad
and it's worse because it's like the
worst month or whatever in the history
but that's with more expensive tickets
so even with the the costing more
they're making less money it's it's
[ __ ] brutal to watch these movies
sometimes i can't stand these new movies
i can't i watch two or three movies a
[ __ ] year that's it yeah you know
unless somebody talks me into it like i
watched the girl with the golden globe
what was the name the girl with the
green flower the dragon tattoo did i
watch that i watched the the one about
uh
the kid who was born with a leaf with
jennifer gardner oh that's you know i
haven't seen that that's a disney movie
you know my wife's pregnant i can't take
a [ __ ] shoot him up harry you know
she's pregnant the kid will do backflips
in the [ __ ] groin whatever the [ __ ]
it is hey
remind me today i got a call from one of
my brothers it's called this we got some
great calls this week so wednesday we
got martin perez his father was batista
the driver in cuba me and martin grew up
in the seventh grade he disappeared and
uh we didn't we never i never knew what
happened and then one day i was doing a
show to miami and probably martin showed
up this [ __ ] that's calling
today his name is frankie
balozzano oh [ __ ] this is carmine
balzano's son that i have kept in touch
with over the years you know they had
four boys and uh one of them died in the
eighth grade
and that made me tired with the family
but it was crazy i was telling lee yes i
go lee you know how you a kid's gotta
[ __ ] that chocolate got pepper in it
today oh really yeah there's the fire
they put a it's uh orange and a little
[ __ ] pepper in there so it's like a
pepper chocolate something for white
people they like all that [ __ ] when they
can smooth around oh my god this
chocolate is delicious speaking of white
people
i'm gonna tell you what bothers me the
most in the [ __ ] world i'm spanish i
was born spanish i love everything about
the fool of the heritage i love the
culture
but once you get to california that's
where it turns because all of a sudden
they have like these armor awards and
all this
awards and people latino that [ __ ] has
always dr the top 10 influential specs
in the country andy garcia it's the same
[ __ ] lineup like gloria makes the
list twice you know what i'm saying
that'd be a good award to a top 10 most
influential yeah the [ __ ] most
influential latinos these [ __ ] specs
let me tell you something i'm a [ __ ]
cuban and i was raised cuban i like
mexicans i like all spanish people you
know whatever i love them i love it i
love all that [ __ ] but once you move to
la it's like they want to be [ __ ] you
know like republicans they want to have
like milk romney with the [ __ ] head
dude they're all gathering around oh
como star and they kiss each other
and they cheat twice and then the
biggest bunch of [ __ ] pukes you know
like nobody ever called me i got the
longest shot and also like four latin
organizations calling me hispanic
whatever of america come join us and i
went to one thing i had to drive to like
universal city i walked in and i walked
out i didn't want to be around because i
you know it's like when we had steve
bauer on the
beast we were talking i was asking him
about his upbringing and i felt out of
place like i'm from the crazy ass
[ __ ] cube in santoria my father's
into numbers my mother was into numbers
my stepfather was with abacua they shot
people usually cubans are pretty cool
like if you go to pasadena i've talked
about this before they got those cubans
that don't know they had black blood in
their [ __ ] they got blood you were
telling me they called the congo yeah
they called the congo and [ __ ] in cuba
they're the racist [ __ ] in the
world but there's white cuban don't know
that they got black blood and every time
you remind them they have a [ __ ]
heart attack they have a you put like
mambo music only potato they'll lose
their [ __ ] mind you know turn it off
we don't want it even the reminders who
the [ __ ] you are yeah but these
[ __ ] out here and it's mexicans
too like i love mexican mike angle
gabriel felipe spazzo believe barcelona
who willie barcena his uh
special showtime special and you know i
know these [ __ ] guys when i was a kid
i wanted to be mexican i mean mexicans
got the [ __ ] beard and they had those
leather things with the bullets in them
and [ __ ]
you know when i see them in the [ __ ]
clinician what the [ __ ] uh what do
you call that [ __ ] with the poncho and
the gun all that stuff it has so much
rich culture but when you meet them at
those [ __ ] alma awards you see all
these little spanish people that play on
tv they up it up even more like there's
people that aren't even spanish that
they have like a 12 spanish their
grandmother blew a [ __ ] argentinian
in the [ __ ]
running the [ __ ] ship ride somewhere
and they'll cop to be in spanish just to
be able to go to those award shows yeah
do you follow them saying like also they
find this jew blood in them oh my god
but i tell you i'm 12 percent
jewish yeah every [ __ ] week that it's
the biggest bunch of fake [ __ ] puerto
ricans i've ever seen in my life and i
like puerto ricans i like cubans and
they're going to be pissed at me but
it's the truth when you see these
[ __ ] and these award shows
they're [ __ ] spanish but they're
trying to act like [ __ ] republicans
they're trying to make believe like
they're they're in beverly [ __ ] hills
and at the end of the week you're
[ __ ] not at the end of the weekend
you know you got to be accept who the
[ __ ] you are you know i'm cuban you know
i look [ __ ] jewish i look [ __ ]
italian i look all this [ __ ] i don't
give a [ __ ] i'm who the hell i am i
don't have to go to those award things
to prove my love for latin [ __ ]
culture i love more and i am the [ __ ]
culture league you mix a little [ __ ]
jewish in there forget about it they
can't stop us i'm like maya lasky and
ricky ricardo put the guy
the [ __ ] you think you're kidding
[ __ ] what happened what time is
he's gonna call up uh it's in about four
minutes okay we woke up the dog but no
it's it's true like
you show more by sticking with the
culture and and that at home then when
they go to the award shows and they go
up to mariachi music and better yeah
yeah they're super all of a sudden
they're more spanish than anybody and
that's always destroyed my [ __ ]
inside and i didn't know it was like
that till i i got fired from telemundo
my first [ __ ] job i booked for after
it was a telemundo some spanish show i'm
telling mundo and i went up there i did
good in the audition but when i went up
there was cubans it was the uncle from
the george lopez show he he recruited
years later as the uncle okay
i went up there and when i sat at the
table and i spoke they're like where are
you from they were like miami cubans
and they're like where are you from i'm
like union city [ __ ] [ __ ]
and these [ __ ] looked at me and
then we started talking in spanish and
my spanish was too fat for them my
spanish was too [ __ ]
like cuban [ __ ] as they call it for
them yeah because you actually learned
from someone who was from cuba right and
it was funny that when i
came back at lunch they fired me and i
could see that they wouldn't look me and
yeah but i didn't give a [ __ ] they paid
for my after okay yo
they paid a thousand bucks after it was
like 800. so after taxes i think i had
to throw on another hundred dollars and
i was made after so they did me a
[ __ ] favor i didn't really want to be
there sometimes people do your [ __ ]
favor you don't even know they're doing
your [ __ ] favor but i just didn't
want to be around those people i felt
very insecure i would go over and go how
do i want to be around these cuban
people because they thought they were
[ __ ] high
my mother's maiden name is valdez my
father is a diaz my [ __ ] maiden name
i'm valdez those are bloodsuckers they
were nine people in the [ __ ] house
they grew up poor yeah but the diaz is
they were rich they were coming away and
when i met the grandmother she was very
snooty when they have like spain blood
and then oh okay
they think their [ __ ] don't stink i'll
smack you dumb [ __ ] we're from
[ __ ] a real cube and you're showing
up and yet
go suck my [ __ ] dick i don't need
that [ __ ] [ __ ] everybody gotta want
to be a [ __ ] everybody wants to be a
star lately leon you know what i'm
saying these [ __ ]
what else god suck i'm gonna have to
take another hit here i'm stoned
no it's it's it's uh it's unbelievable
we were taught and it's just
the culture of fakes and the iphone's
coming out and people are going to be
lined up around the block for that and
it's just it's unbelievable
oh my god that one hit the bottom of the
[ __ ] lung i gotta go doctor amy
needle in the bottom to chase all this
[ __ ] out but
i just never thought i'd see phonies
like that
with spanish people i never saw it
growing up and i i never thought i'd see
it but when you go to those events oh my
god so it's so hard
they're trying
to be
latin but they're really being [ __ ]
wasps yeah and when you go you're like
what's the point what's the what's the
point of making believe that you're
representing the culture if you're
trying to [ __ ] act like a different
culture be yourself that's the bottom
[ __ ] line what's the music there a
little cyberbloody sabbath on a monday
for years when i woke up lee and i was
heartbroken this is a song that always
got me together reminding me of where
the [ __ ] i lived why i was getting up in
the morning you fell i'm saying to me a
little sabbath bloody right there
[Music]
oh youtube was [ __ ] up
[Music]
don't blame it on youtube [ __ ]
check and see for this kid to call dog
here you go
he's calling no he's not you sure you
could tell right there got something
yeah what else did you do this weekend
lee i got to tell you what else happened
this weekend real quick okay when i went
to minneapolis i did a podcast for a guy
named tom bernard oh that was great if
people haven't listened to it it's great
you haven't listened to the top i didn't
even know who the [ __ ] tom bernard was
and uh they contacted me and i went uh
to minneapolis and they said you know
you're in good hands everybody was like
you're doing tom bernard this guy's
[ __ ] bad and what i didn't know was
it's one of the markets they threw out
stern
oh stern's not there because this guy
beat the [ __ ] out of him supposedly i
don't know what the numbers were or
whatever
so i go to the [ __ ] guys at first i
got to do the radio station that he does
he does like a regular radio show yeah
on minneapolis i do that and then i have
to go to his house to do the podcast wow
he had the [ __ ] coat remember where
tony montana went to meet the colombian
yeah that's the type of house he had a
bad [ __ ] [ __ ] a lake in the
backyard [ __ ] beautiful just a
beautiful fireplace his wife was
beautiful his whole family was there he
had like [ __ ] four other people in
the podcast
and it's just i miss all that [ __ ]
home feeling sometimes that's what i
yearn for out here that family home
[ __ ] feeling yeah you must be around
them all day because i was i listened
and he says he does the radio show from
home
so he he never has to leave his house no
he's like a lycus in minneapolis but you
had to see his [ __ ] house how
gorgeous it was and he had a lake in his
[ __ ] backyard how nice would it be to
invite somebody over dinner they say
something wrong you stab them
and you put them in a carpet and throw
them in the [ __ ] lake where they
belong i mean it's just such a [ __ ]
great
and the guy his family you know the guy
called me on saturday he goes you know
i've been on the road i know what it is
to be alone if you want to go eat
something today or tomorrow just the
hospitality so please keep supporting
tom bannon i mean what a [ __ ]
sweetheart of a guy he's my type of guy
like he's paying my [ __ ] news for me
because we did the podcast and then he
was headed to go do a thing for nuns and
30 years earlier you know i choked the
[ __ ] nun
so now he went over what's going on lee
because if i'm talking to you you're not
looking at me i don't know what the [ __ ]
you're doing you're looking at some
guy's comments no i'm just waiting for
the call all right brother cause i i
don't know what you're doing over there
you're making me nervous you look at the
[ __ ] thing
like uh you know somebody took your
thing oh lee reminded me today the
occupiers are coming out those [ __ ]
half of memos but you know what they're
gonna come out and go right back in once
the iphone goes out on sale yeah so it
don't matter that's why they just
prepared them staying online you know
what i'm saying yeah i read an article
it's like the one year anniversary yeah
the one yeah i'm in boston they still
have meetings but like four people show
up and they're all 65. these guys
couldn't [ __ ] commit to them this is
like the deadheads had more commitment
to these [ __ ] jerk-offs they really
did the deadheads had more commitments
as these filthy [ __ ] because
the same thing happened away it started
great they were marching around the tv
cameras came down back comics started
going down there it was a big [ __ ]
media outlet and what happened didn't do
nothing the cameras left and i gave them
ideas i said this is what you got you
got to hit these [ __ ] in the
pocket you got to [ __ ] take one
corporation every day and take them to
the [ __ ] cleaners don't use them you
know they want to charge for luggage or
whatever the [ __ ] it is that they want
to do just don't use them that's what
you do but they went down there for six
days they stopped taking showers they
were smoking dope then the iphone came
on the trust fund check came in and bam
there they are back standing online on
the [ __ ] iphone this country's
starting to stand they love
you know when i was a kid you didn't
stand like a dick
dick okay now a [ __ ] movie you people
you people love standing online like you
[ __ ] russians what's next you want to
stand online for toilet paper you
[ __ ] saps i've never stood online i
don't believe in [ __ ] standing online
even at an airport yesterday even if i
have a regular plane ticket i go through
[ __ ] first class and i'm gonna throw
it yeah they're not gonna throw you i
just say i didn't know
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you you guys
pay attention bro when i go through an
airport i go in and out of that [ __ ]
airport because i buy like a thing like
i'll buy like early boarding
i'll buy like the bigger seats but i'll
confuse it
i'll go up and go oh i didn't know
that
once you're in line you're gonna send
your back no they process you and now
you've got you go through what the [ __ ]
is wrong with people you don't stand
online you never stand on [ __ ] line
we're all pimps the [ __ ] is wrong with
people we don't stand in line for nobody
unless they got a gun for you let's go
to this club and go for you are you
[ __ ] kidding me i go to vegas
sometimes i see these momos waiting
waiting online to buy the one that kills
me the most is that restaurant on sunset
i'm fairfax the breakfast place
with all these fake [ __ ] people the
same spanish people who go to those
awards they call their white buddies and
they go over to the [ __ ] breakfast
guys did you people know in l.a
people stand online for breakfast huge
lines and here's where it gets better
right across the street there's a bagel
place that'll make a [ __ ] locked
bagel for you that'll make your head
spin with nice onions and you know real
[ __ ] jew [ __ ] these dumb [ __ ] wait
online 45 minutes because years ago
uh
uh what's her name
no [ __ ] marilyn monroe wasn't alive
you dumb [ __ ] the other one you [ __ ]
the check with your lindsay lohan they
breakfast in there before court okay so
they [ __ ] went there
and the cameras took it so now all these
tourists go there in the morning they
stand online and listen the breakfast is
okay at best you know it's eggs
it's [ __ ] eggs these [ __ ] idiots
it's eggs
and people stand on line with their
newspapers that they're going to do
something big don't stand online guys we
don't do that [ __ ] we're the
[ __ ] united states these idiots
that go to clubs with their girlfriends
and wait to get picked and all this dumb
[ __ ] are you [ __ ] kidding me that's
one thing i've never understood i i
don't like going like going to club and
waiting 45 minutes and going it doesn't
make sense it doesn't make sense and
these people will go you go to vegas you
go to these [ __ ] clubs like sometimes
joe and after a fight they'll go let's
go up here we gotta invite i go up to
these people at these clubs that i
wouldn't let them in 20 [ __ ] years
ago a bunch of housewives and [ __ ]
dancing all fat fat guy what the [ __ ]
are you doing here you're in no danger
go back to your room and play monopoly
yeah you're a new [ __ ] that you're
just taking a butt whatever they'll take
a dollar from [ __ ] everybody and let
them in tonight give us a [ __ ] they be
calling you no not yet it's just crazy
what's up before he calls this this
thing happened we talk a lot about uh
people who do things to get in the wrong
way and i for people who i work i'm as i
work on a tv show and one of my bosses
quit on saturday night he just quit he
wasn't coming back and the reason he
quit was and i like him he said he got
mad because our boss wanted us at our
desk at five o'clock when we get there
starting to work and he's like oh this
is the entertainment industry show up
half an hour half an hour within half an
hour and you just enjoy it as long as we
get our work done and i agree with them
in a way but who who quit the job
because your boss wants you there when
it starts and start to work and just
this people in this town are weird like
it didn't make sense to me first of all
it's [ __ ] brilliant you brought that
up because
when in this town especially it's all
about images and appearances okay god
forbid these [ __ ] momos first of all
they love running late to break your
balls in this town yeah and i remember
when i got the longest shot people
saying to me when you go to these
meetings an agent particularly girls get
there 15 minutes late
that's the way to do it make them wait
for you i hate that and
you know it's all great but whatever but
inside of me something was wrong i did
it like once or twice
i didn't like it because i don't like
people being late to [ __ ] meet me
yeah and then i started going to
meetings and people were late to meet me
and it was like oh sorry the traffic and
one day i went to this meeting for like
fox or something this young kid for fox
21
and i remember he came in with that
story and i said something to him
i'm like dog the meeting was a [ __ ]
10 o'clock it's 10 35.
really really the 405 was that [ __ ]
packed you live in california you know
you got a plan time ahead so i did the
opposite i said you know what [ __ ] that
[ __ ] to work on my character i'm gonna
go in there you know people forget like
for me i never [ __ ] forgot that
uh
you know before you became a comic
you're a [ __ ] man you gotta act like
a [ __ ] man that's why i love joe
rogan with all my heart and i want you
guys to give him all the light in the
world because i know joe for 15 years
and joe has brought me more [ __ ]
stakes than anybody joe has done more
for me and one of the things that
disappointed me people say oh you don't
go to the communist world my answer is i
don't go down there because you need to
close one door before you open up
another one but the truth of the [ __ ]
matter is the reason why i don't go down
there is because when they threw joe out
and gersh got rid of joe for jamming of
carlos that friday night all these
comics were going to get together and
they were going to protest the comedy
store for getting rid of them well mitzi
shaw said whoever protests at the comedy
store
was not allowed to come back wow so all
these comedians said [ __ ] the protest
[ __ ] what joe rogan did for us and they
went back i don't talk to those people i
don't see those guys i don't want to
associate with them that's why i don't
go to the [ __ ] store somebody hit me
today we're doing a show in april we
need you at the store i wouldn't step
foot in the [ __ ] store out of respect
for joe because i know what joe did joe
stood up for all these [ __ ]
these are the same people that were in
the back of that video clapping and
jumping up and down and now when they
see carlos they hug him and they kiss
him so i don't [ __ ] deal with
comments for that [ __ ] because they got
no [ __ ] loyalty to themselves and
that's one point like i was still
snorting coke when that went down but
well i don't know if i was i don't know
what year was i think i was at home
snorting but that was one thing that
made me open up my eyes that i don't
want to hang out with people don't have
my [ __ ] back you run with me
you gotta have my back and i have your
back till this day i won't step foot in
the [ __ ] store because out of respect
for joe he's my friend he's done more
for [ __ ] me and anybody giving them
[ __ ] life and that's what you do with
your friends you support your [ __ ]
friends you don't go to the store and
mingle or whatever it's over i don't
need them that [ __ ] bad i stuck to my
[ __ ] guns it's like when people say
you don't tax no i don't [ __ ] tax why
not because there's no hundred dollar
bills that come to the tax and there's
all these misunderstandings it's your
football field this [ __ ] life it's
not life's football field it's your
football field and you make the calls
you decide what you're going to do and
what you're not going to know what
you're going to stick to it for years
and i did blow
i wasn't a sheep but i was very quiet
because god forbid my little secret got
out god forbid that i stopped doing blow
okay that would be very
i would i would still tell you to suck
my dick but i'd get in my car and go
home and once i stopped doing blow that
was part of it i wanted to get my
character back into this [ __ ]
which is all balls that's what i'm
[ __ ] about i don't give a [ __ ] about
where they're gonna put me you know this
in this town nobody will say no to you
on the phone literally
because you might become a star and they
might need you for something else years
later uh-huh and that's what's always
[ __ ] killed me you got to say what
the [ __ ] you saying what's on your mind
if not you might as well suck they can
get on all fours that's just the
beginning of the [ __ ] end once you go
against what you believe you might as
well bend the [ __ ] over so i don't do it
no more and i haven't done it for five
six seven ten [ __ ] years and that's
why nobody's even heard of me because i
wouldn't take [ __ ] from nobody just to
be in a movie or a tv show and some
comedy special i don't need that [ __ ]
who the [ __ ] is this guy put some music
on let me call this [ __ ] and see
why he hasn't called it's 6 41.
i don't know where this [ __ ] is
at maybe he got the wrong number
there you go a little something for the
spirits out there
i play this every every time i wake up
in the morning i play especially on
mondays out of respect for my mother
there's something in your [ __ ] light
playing light a candle
you're going to call or what
[Music]
here's what i'm talking about
some people
just another [ __ ] satisfied
you know what i'm saying but anyway
that's what we're talking about it'll be
a good calling cause i don't know
but you said you have something very
interesting that you you say you said
like in the last testicle testaments you
say uh when you used to be a criminal of
someone if they cheated on their wife or
their girlfriend you wouldn't do
business with them because what would
they do to me like it doesn't make sense
doesn't make sense problem doesn't make
sense you look at the whole [ __ ]
thing and i got that from carlo gambino
you know it was one of carlo gambino's
main thing but it's true if they cheat
on their wife they'll [ __ ] rat on you
yeah and that's it you know
i just uh didn't like what went down
years ago and i took car i took uh and i
don't have anything against carlos i
really don't i see carlos i shake his
hand i got nothing against carlos you
know i told him years ago he said
something to me during 9 11. i think
carlos knows i'll hit him in the [ __ ]
head you know i don't give a [ __ ] you
know what really got them mad at me what
really got everybody mad at me was that
marilyn martinez's wake
they used to be a comedian they met in
martinez
and there's this guy in town jeff valdez
he runs ctv he was a comic and uh he
puts together latino life festival and
[ __ ] the guy [ __ ] me in maryland over
our first year he made me showcase like
10 times okay and he wanted me to work
clean and he goes no you didn't get into
a festival and then after that he had
like a dirty show
to the fast class i never forgot that
you know it was my first year here it
really hurt my [ __ ] feelings you know
i didn't know how the business work i
just believed in men's work yeah i
thought that a man had his [ __ ] words
so i didn't know i came old school but
these [ __ ] don't have their
[ __ ] words for anything they won't
even look in the eye when they talk to
you so this went on for years and then
he put me in the festival the following
year but it still didn't click with me
what he had done it never [ __ ]
resonated into uh
like i just didn't like him and then he
kept [ __ ] with marilyn
marilyn he had some show on ctv and he
kept [ __ ] maryland then he called me
to do some show one day i'm not kidding
you lee he offered me 50
and i'm sitting there going i don't like
this guy
yeah so i don't want to even [ __ ] do
it you know and i called back and i
don't want to do it and then he called
back in he goes i'll give you 500
so that's how much of a thief he is he
went from 50 to 500 most people go from
50 to 100 he went for 500 and he paid me
the money and it was okay but
bro i i forgive but i don't [ __ ]
forget
something about this guy and marilyn
kept telling me kept [ __ ] with her
and then marilyn dies of cancer and i
fly back home i'm in new york for a
benefit and i [ __ ] come back and the
next thing you know
uh
i go to the wake i go to the church
because they usually have a you know
awake and then they do church i wasn't
here for the weight so i made it for the
church okay then they had the funeral
and then that night they had a thing at
the comedy store so i went to this
uh
lee talk look at me i went to this
[ __ ] uh
wake right i go to his wake and
this church function first in the
morning and i see jeff valdez
and i'm thinking to myself what the [ __ ]
is this puke doing here yeah you know
he's there what the [ __ ] he doing here
and i didn't say nothing i just played
it off i waved down he waved them he
didn't talk to me
and then that night i wasn't going to go
to the i had just finished i just
stopped doing blow okay i hadn't i
hadn't done blow for like maybe six
nights all right i'm about to choke
myself but uh super bad i had a problem
and i made it up uh
a promise that if god saved superbad i
would never do blow again and i was up
to the sixth night and this is marilyn's
dead now
and they call me i'm going like you have
to go to the store she was your best
friend i didn't want to be down i don't
like none of that [ __ ] i always think
that especially in hollywood they turn
into a celebrity thing yeah it's not
about really the pain or what people are
going through
so uh
uh next thing you know
who shows up [ __ ] jeff valdez but
it's even worse they have food in the
back okay i see him eating the [ __ ]
food
i just see him eating the food and i'm
burning so i got no blowing me i just
lost one of my best friends and now i
got this [ __ ] and i'm at the
thing and somebody goes you should go up
to the stage first you never know about
this lady no i've heard i've heard parts
of this i go up there to the stage first
and i'm on stage i'm talking to my man
how much i'm going to miss her and i
just keep seeing jeff valdez sitting
there with his wife and his lawyer and i
just [ __ ] go off i just stopped like
i can't do this no more ladies and
gentlemen i couldn't i couldn't sit
there with this [ __ ] guy being phony
and i just tore her into him because he
said his claim to famous he's have
jewish and half mexican okay and i'll
make you too [ __ ] greasy to be a
[ __ ] jew you're too much of a piece
of [ __ ] and you're too greasy to be a
[ __ ] mexican you're a piece of [ __ ]
he was a wife and his lawyer with it oh
jesus people are like get off the stage
and i'm going at him i'm like [ __ ] you
you slimy [ __ ] and he's like
[ __ ] you my name's on the wall too here
at the store because he's no comic he's
never said a funny thing in his life
okay and i go [ __ ] you if i get off the
stage i'm gonna go over and make you
suck my dick
and dice and all these guys there and i
go listen one more thing i'm going to
get off the stage i'm gonna go in the
barn i'm gonna do a [ __ ] shot when i
come back in if i see you at this
[ __ ] thing i'm going off on you that
was i went off yeah i went to the bar
and sure and people knew they were
following me they knew i would have
[ __ ] killed them how i felt that
night i went in there him and his wife
and his [ __ ] attorney left
they [ __ ] wrote an article about in
the paper i was gonna hook it up this
morning oh [ __ ] you have to wait for
that gun off
and the [ __ ] listen to what happened
he called the newspaper and threatened
the suit the newspaper putting the story
in there oh i thought you meant he put
it in the paper no no the papers did but
the la times did the front page of
entertainment
so the [ __ ] next thing you know
uh
you know i'm getting calls and all this
[ __ ] i can't believe you like all these
people went against me knowing that this
jeff valdez was the biggest piece of
[ __ ] some of the mexicans stuck up for
me they were like bro what you did was
bro again a mexican tortures mexicans
and [ __ ] cubans got to come to the
rescue because god forbid somebody say
something to hurt their feelings you
know what uh i'm not the funniest guy in
the world and i'm not the best actor and
i'm the best writer but i know i got a
lot of heart and i know i always [ __ ]
work you know every once in a while
somebody needs a smack on the [ __ ]
head so i didn't see this guy for like
two or three years 2007 i didn't see him
for like two or three years and i was
doing the ice house i know i know this
story and uh and it's funny because
felicia wanted to come up to the ice
house with me one night and i go alright
let's go up there this was way before
beauty and the beast and the next thing
you [ __ ] know
i go up there
and rudy calls me he goes jeff's going
to be up here tonight you know is there
going to be a problem lego i won't say
nothing unless he says something okay so
he started in early i'm in the green
room running my business he comes into
the agreement we don't belong in the
agreement he comes into the he's doing a
guess and he ain't even a [ __ ] comic
he comes into the green room he's
talking all this [ __ ] you know i'm here
and he's half drunk and i don't say a
word and then i walk out and he's
sitting there with shane forbes talking
about some [ __ ] and he looks at me he
goes uh and shane goes are you gonna be
cool tonight joey and i go it all
depends on this [ __ ]
and we went at it and this [ __ ]
is sitting there going [ __ ] you let's
fight he's calling me out he's calling
me out lee [ __ ] you you're a fat [ __ ]
you're a coke fiend he's saying all this
[ __ ] to me right and i'm like whatever
you [ __ ] [ __ ] he goes let's go
outside
so i looked at him and i go i'm gonna
[ __ ] this [ __ ] but i'm gonna
throw him for a lube one tuero style i
was just gonna say it sounded like your
father i looked at him and i spit in his
[ __ ] face with one of those good weed
clammies
and as he went to spit back at me i
ducked and i got him with a bit slap to
the bottom of the chin very lightly and
this [ __ ] pops up and he's like
i'm calling the police all that [ __ ] you
talk for 20 minutes out you're a tough
guy and let's fight now you're calling
the police but it's hysterical because
he [ __ ] uh
we getting you know me a cop ain't gonna
catch me by the time your hand hit his
face
i was already walking towards the
[ __ ] car and the beauty of it is that
i picked my buddy rick ramos i'm walking
with him and i wa and he's like joey
what are you gonna do i go come on rick
just stay close give me a ride home
because felicia drove me up there okay
so it's funny because i'm walking out
the cops are coming in the [ __ ]
hallway as usual and they can't tell
it's me because they're looking at body
language i know how to avoid the [ __ ]
cops i slow down my body language like
nothing's going on yeah and there's a
helicopter hey bro oh it's pasadena you
know these [ __ ] momo's you can't do
nothing i get in the car with rick we
hit the one street and then we hit the
main street to hit the [ __ ] 134 to
get east
and right there the phone rings and it's
philippe and he goes fool where are you
i go i'm in the car what's going on up
there the cops they goes yeah they're
scraping the spit off his face and
putting in a csi bag right he's saying
all this [ __ ] to me right
and i'm loving it my dick you know in my
mind i had closure from maryland
maryland had a problem with a black
closure for me sometimes you gotta smack
somebody in the face to get [ __ ]
closure so
i come home
and uh the next day the [ __ ] cops
called me and nobody said a word they
told them nothing and they've gotten on
all the [ __ ] mexicans the real
mexicans didn't say a word they
interviewed everybody the staff at the
ice house got interviewed i was gonna
say when we do that the testicle
testaments
they still come up and talk to like dude
that's funny oh yeah they still come up
and say years later that was great that
night when you smacked them dog
everybody left because people know in
this town when you deserve a smack the
problem with this town is they don't
want to throw the smack but they don't
want to call you a [ __ ] because they
won't work again and at the end of the
day your manhood all that [ __ ]
madness because if you don't have your
manhood in your [ __ ] you got dick in
this [ __ ] life you might as well bend
over and let the [ __ ] arabs and
russians everybody else [ __ ] [ __ ] the
ass that's all what the [ __ ] is going on
over there in the embassies huh it's
[ __ ] crazy man
i i was watching this video today and it
broke my heart it was uh this guy this
kid like younger than me 21 was in
afghanistan he called home he was two
days from coming home and he said hey
dad you have to tell mom i don't think
i'm coming home because they have a big
problem over there now where the the
afghani police officers they're training
are killing them because they don't want
them there so this 21 year old kid he
knew something was going to happen and
on the base
they're getting shot now like like like
every other week there's new people
getting shot and it's just i actually
had a kid i went to high school with a
couple of them die and it's just it's uh
it's unbelievable it's it's it's
heartbreaking that's [ __ ] amazing man
it's gonna end december 12th i thought
it was my baby coming that's the end of
the world the [ __ ] you know my
wife is pregnant that's my end of my
[ __ ] world right there but i didn't
know and all of a sudden you'll read
about all these embassies and all this
other [ __ ] and what's cracker lacking in
the [ __ ] world
and that's it man i i can't [ __ ]
believe frankie lost a [ __ ] number
that's all right you know it just
[ __ ] goes to
so but you know what put some music on
for these [ __ ] maybe i'll get martin
perez to call all right [ __ ] me find
some music let me get martin perez to
call real quick if he could do it if he
could do it we'll talk to [ __ ] martin
perez and blow you [ __ ] out of
the water yeah that'd be great and
martin perez is a great story he like
his father was the driver for that guy
that's a batista you're [ __ ] batista
the godfather you know what i'm saying
so let's [ __ ] make this happen
where are you at you're still [ __ ]
you on your way
oh you're in your car i don't know if
you could call in i thought you would be
in your office and you could call from a
solid phone but we'll do martin perez on
[ __ ] wednesday all right
i love you [ __ ] i got you on the
phone right now i love you my thing
but
yeah martin perez was going to call
originally when i talked to frank he
goes no i'll call for it martin perez is
going to be a great [ __ ] story mark
perez's father is one of batista's
[ __ ] drivers that's unbelievable what
happened was i went to eddie's house a
few weeks already bravo's house watching
tv with his wife or whatever
and he had a documentary on about cuba
and the next thing you [ __ ] know uh
if i see martin perez they're talking
about him on tv yeah they're doing a
documentary about batista oh [ __ ] often
they showed all these pictures from 1950
and batista and i see martin perez
standing next to him not the kid that's
calling in his father you [ __ ] momo
what the [ __ ] are you okay today yeah
are you okay today marilyn monroe really
you [ __ ] i should still stab you from
before i don't know how old the egg
right that's why i need you smoking dope
in the morning
how to beg you he's taking these little
hits like a 16 year old girl sucking a
dick you ever seen when a 16 year old
sucks a dick oh they suck it like they
don't want that's how he was i had to
get the lighter and force them because i
got to say it's six in the morning
that's when you're supposed to get high
is the church of what's happening now
how are you going to show up with no
[ __ ] bullets in your gun
hold on
the first part of the day that's the
price listen i've had a [ __ ] for the
last hour put that air on for two
minutes i'm sweating i'm telling you
guys
it's go oh that's what's tremendous
i gotta light a candle i gotta light it
again that's the best i work in like in
an office when the room's closed that's
the best when you're alone and you fart
and it's just the doors closed and it's
it's the most fun thing in the world
you're disgusting you know i don't want
this fart on nobody you just said it was
amazing yeah for me not for me because
i'm here sitting like i'm in an office
alone by myself listen the best thing in
life i fought on the there was a guy on
the plane yesterday somebody smelled
like [ __ ] armpit oh and it was either
the guy next to me or the guy to from me
you know and i'll tolerate [ __ ]
armpit for two seconds there's nothing
worse than when somebody [ __ ] hugs
you and they put the armpit on your
[ __ ] arm and you have a 10 30 show
later on like that's why after [ __ ]
shows if you got armpit don't come over
to me go shake my hand from a distance
because that [ __ ] onion smell
destroys my insides it [ __ ] destroys
me lately i don't like that onion smell
this [ __ ] sat next to me
yesterday
first off
i get the premium seats i didn't have
enough points for the first class on
this flight okay so i just got the
larger leg room and the premium seat so
i always get the early board so i get on
there first and put my [ __ ] on the
overhead that's a sleep apnea machine i
don't travel with a [ __ ] computer i
gotta travel with a sleep apnea machine
it's like four thousand dollars
you know and i don't want to lose that
thing if it falls or something the
computer timing goes off it's a computer
in there oh okay you don't have to send
the card for you guys that have sleep
apnea have a couple different machines i
forget the one i have it's two level
that's why when they test you they test
you by level okay and what i do with
mine is i take the computer card out
once a month i put an envelope and i
mailed it and they sent me a report and
they sent the other report to my doctor
okay so you can see what i'm doing every
night every night by the [ __ ] thing
don't even break it down if you have
alcohol because you'll be dehydrated oh
[ __ ] so it breaks it [ __ ] down so
this thing is very sensitive like it has
a humidifier and a lot of sleep apneas
for people who don't know sleep apnea is
when you have [ __ ] you're a fat [ __ ]
your neck gets big and you don't have to
be fat joe rogan has it eddie bravo has
it putting a certain amount of weight on
i think it's chest weight or whatever is
around here or something i don't know
how it works you know wikipedia it's the
number one growing disease in men and
people die from it people [ __ ] die
that's right rachel got it going what's
his name had it the football player the
philadelphia eagle okay defensive end
that's how it got that year uh the web
page was getting 25 000 hits a year the
day he died it got 25 000 hits that day
because men didn't know they just kept
saying i have a problem sleeping maybe
they're single nobody knows they're
snoring that [ __ ] will kill you because
it raises your blood pressure it [ __ ]
me up i was up to 4 15. that's why i
have you know when people consider diets
they always say well i'm eating better
and i'm going for a walk if you don't
sleep eight hours
and all that [ __ ] means nothing because
your cortisol levels go up yeah you're
telling me yesterday goes into shock
when i was at 415 i was already starting
to get the bella lugosi look with the
ball on my neck you know
it was [ __ ] crazy you know and once
you see that because at night when
you're trying to breathe your body goes
into [ __ ] danger your body's in
danger
it thinks you're dying so it's not
shooting out that [ __ ] cortisol
that's like the [ __ ] uh the [ __ ] joe
rogan talks about dmt it's the last
thing that your brain sees before you
die so that's why you get all happy you
know what cortisol don't work like i'm
just teasing you [ __ ] but
that's why you start getting that ball
on your neck when you see fat people
they start getting that ball in their
neck and the back of their necks getting
big
they got one for the grave one of banana
peel because that's it that quarter's
off taking over that's where the
diabetes that's why all this [ __ ] and i
may be wrong i'm gonna read it up but i
know what i'm talking about because i
looked into this [ __ ]
yeah i lived it i mean i knew i couldn't
breathe i couldn't do anything so i get
on the [ __ ] plane earlier that's the
point of the story lee yeah and i put my
bag over it so i could watch it okay
this dumb [ __ ] doesn't get early
boarding he sits next to me and i'm
sitting there with my ipod on and i look
up and i see this [ __ ] taking my
bag on right away i called time out why
is your hands on my back yeah he said
well i gotta put four thousand dollars
out that's not gonna do with me i told
him the truck i'm gonna do with me you
should have been here early that's my
bag leave it up there and he just looked
at me and people come and touch my
compartment i don't know a lot of people
sit like in 22d and i'm like in 6a and
they want to put [ __ ] in my thing no dog
that's my [ __ ] thing i paid for the
seat if it's filled and all three of us
have our [ __ ] in that compartment then
you can put it because everybody today
wants to fly with carry-on the more
carry on you bring on for you to zip in
and out of there whatever the [ __ ] you
do the more carry on you [ __ ] bring
on the more [ __ ] troubles gonna be
the seating that's why whenever you get
on a plane now at the end people
pointing [ __ ] in they don't know where
to go they tell you checking out the
[ __ ] gate because everybody wasn't a
[ __ ] check your [ __ ] yeah the only
thing you should have on here is your
computer a little bit of wheel in your
nutsack just case a plane goes down
you're not on some [ __ ] island
without nothing you know what i'm saying
because that'd be the worst you float
not there's bad enough but if i had
rolling papers in a baggie waterproof
ones or a pipe and a lighter floating
out there until [ __ ] the this you
know the us army shows up yeah it's
always better and i'm just [ __ ]
around here but i get on this [ __ ]
plane there and these [ __ ] are
stinking up the one one of these two
[ __ ] guys stinks
so after like 15 minutes i gotta say
something i look at both of them and i
go somebody on this [ __ ] flight
forgot to watch their [ __ ] and they
both looked at you oh [ __ ] yeah you know
me
you know me you got to say something you
got to wear a [ __ ] deodorant you
can't go out if you want to stink that's
your personal [ __ ] business but if
you want to sit next to people like a
civilized human being on a plane and
you're going to for three hours and
you're going to smell like [ __ ]
satsiki juice from a gyro that's your i
gotta say something to you cause you're
invading my [ __ ] space it's
like me [ __ ] coming in with with no
armpit and [ __ ] uh sitting next to
you for six hours on a [ __ ] plate you
gotta wash yourself it's [ __ ] what is
it clenny this is nixon godly this yeah
the [ __ ] is wrong with you gotta wash
your [ __ ] before you leave the house
gotta brush your teeth you gotta that's
what the church or what's happening now
is you gotta be sharp you gotta be
[ __ ] these [ __ ] oh we'll go
for breakfast we're gonna take a shower
take a shower it takes you five more
minutes to wash your balls wash your ass
what if you run into a [ __ ] school
bus full of [ __ ] women that haven't
sucked a dick in a year they got a flat
tire and here you are with stinky
[ __ ] nuts because you were going on
to eat breakfast and enough with the
[ __ ] sandals or every time i see
somebody with a sandal a man i step on
that [ __ ] foot on purpose by mistake
i step on that [ __ ] foot you're a
grown [ __ ] man with sandals and they
think they're so [ __ ] cool on the
flight back here yesterday was a bunch
of those bahama mama guys yeah i used to
have this friend this [ __ ] idiot
gavin boy who thought he was a [ __ ]
producer that [ __ ] went out the window
he ended up back in idaho now he's back
here doing short films for some
[ __ ] mook
and he was one of those guys that always
had to have the sandals on he was always
too [ __ ] cool wait till i step on
your [ __ ] foot and see how cool it is
now you got your [ __ ] sandals on what
if godzilla comes and you got sandals on
you start running you lose one of those
[ __ ] sandals now you gotta run like
jesus with one foot [ __ ] flying one
[ __ ] sandal put [ __ ] shoes on and
boots when you leave the house unless
you go to the beach you shouldn't have
[ __ ] sandals on you want to roll or
something and you know what you need but
they want to fly with that [ __ ]
sandals whatever the plane goes down and
we got stuck in [ __ ] cuban you got to
walk a half a mile you gotta think of
this [ __ ] no [ __ ] sandals everybody
thinks they're cool like gilligan
and that's the thing and and then their
feet are thinking it's it's disgusting
put some [ __ ] shoes on you're a grown
[ __ ] man a woman was supposed to see
your toes was supposed to fantasize
about whacking off on that [ __ ] shoe
polish but a [ __ ] man come on man
these [ __ ] guys are out of control
and that's what the church of what's
happening now is about look what the
church of what's happening now is
introduced to me it was introduced to me
by a man named wayne means
i was 27 years old i was about six
months away from getting in trouble for
kidnapping i thought i had a lot of
[ __ ] answers and he took over a
subaru store where i worked that in both
i owe a lot to the guys that i look i
worked there was two guys selling cars i
owe my life to wayne means a guy named
jim handy jim handy was my manager
toyota jim handy came years later jim
handy taught me how to you know he put
together in my mind how to become a
comic how it was possible because the
car lot he would make you write your
goals daily like what are you going to
do today i'm going to sell two cars how
are you going to do that i'm gonna
[ __ ] uh
you know talk to 10 people i'm going to
call 10 people and i'm going to be at my
best you know that's what jim handy
taught me that came later but when i
didn't have a father you know all those
years right before i went to jail i met
this wayne means guy and he used to tell
me bro we're from the church of what's
happening now today we don't give a [ __ ]
what's going to happen next week or next
month today how we're going to make it
happen today well to make it happen
today you're going to be sharp your
hair's got to be calm your [ __ ]
breaths got to be good your shoes have
to be [ __ ] shine your pants gotta
look decent and when you talk to
somebody i look [ __ ] professional any
[ __ ] circle you gotta be sharp with
these people today it's 2012. people are
starving and you want to walk around
with [ __ ] sandals on like a half a
[ __ ] [ __ ] no you're a man get out
there and talk to [ __ ] people that's
what it's all about that's what it's all
this is easy bro yeah but everybody
wants to be somebody else everybody
wants to be a [ __ ] fake look at me
i'm a fat [ __ ] what can i do to change
people with joey you got that 1910 head
dude so what do you want me to do get a
new justin bieber can you imagine uncle
joey with a justin [ __ ] bieber head
dude what's next look at somebody's
[ __ ] for ten dollars what's [ __ ]
next what do you have left if you don't
have your [ __ ] self yeah i don't give
a [ __ ] no more it's all about the reefer
it's monday all i'm doing is trying to
get you the [ __ ] out there to be the
best you can be and to shove it into
these [ __ ] asses before they
try to shove them to you i told you
about saturday this [ __ ] guy in
minneapolis shows up to the show friday
nightly
we're taking pictures sorry i keep
wiping my face if you're watching i got
cat from that [ __ ] finney that [ __ ]
up there's always shedding that skinny
[ __ ] some guy comes out to me friday and
these people who think that you just
walked out of the [ __ ] banana field
there's people who treat me like i just
walked off of the banana field he comes
in
with his wife real cute and they say to
me hey bro can we take a picture sure
let's take a picture i google with them
giggle with them google i giggle with
them getting [ __ ] up on that fire i
giggle with them a little bit and next
thing you know
they're like can we tape something
he's like could you tape something for
me i'm like sure i go what do you want
to say goes holly whatever he's [ __ ]
number one i don't know what his name is
will is gonna win this thing i go will's
gonna win this thing okay all right
that's it thank you man we love you
listen to the podcast boom they leave
next [ __ ] night first show ends i got
all these people we're talking and i see
this guy and i go hey man how are you
doing this remember me from last night i
go yeah you're back you came to the
sugars no he goes this is what happened
my wife didn't hit the [ __ ] tape
button last night jesus so i know we did
it twice we had done it twice i even
gave him another one yeah there's no way
she didn't yeah she didn't hit it so i
go all right we'll do it real quick
let's go over to the uh because we're at
the mall of america have you ever been
to the [ __ ] wall of america
tremendous and don't be a fat [ __ ] and
go to the mall you'll never make it
it's four days of your effect [ __ ] i've
burned a ton of calories there so we got
those
but they got bikes they got dogs you got
gotta be [ __ ] careful so we go
outside we're smoking out there we're
talking to the people and he's lurking
like a pending [ __ ] damn he's there
giggling at my jokes we're all talking
he's there giggling trying to be cute
and finally the lines draws down a
little bit he walks over and he's like
so you're ready to do it and i'm there
with two other comics they're doing
they're getting like a pipe full ready
and he goes all right let's do this man
and also he goes you're ready to go and
i go yeah i'm also gonna go hold on let
me get my friend with the camera
your friend with a [ __ ] camera
he's like this is what we're going to do
tonight you're going to tell him because
i'm doing a
poker tournament so i want you to say
this up front can you remember this and
he's just saying this speech to me and i
look i'm like oh yo
we're in the middle of a [ __ ] show
here i got to go do another show you
[ __ ] scared and even if you weren't
yeah i go are you [ __ ] serious i
don't know what get the [ __ ] out of here
i'm doing what i did last night he said
come on man can't you do it i go no
we're doing what we [ __ ] did last
night and let's [ __ ] do this and he's
pissed i could tell he's literally
pissed but these people want to take
advantage like i need to do an
advertising for his [ __ ] bowling or
his
poker [ __ ] league instead of just
telling me the truth he's trying to
connive that his wife didn't play tape i
looked him right in the face and i go
i'll tape some but i'm gonna take what i
did last night
yeah i could see that he was like
what about your agent should i go no
you're trying to pull a quick one on me
you're trying to take [ __ ] advantage
of me you know this father is a
friendship i don't want no [ __ ] fans
i really don't i told roger like with
this they know fans fans are always a
little kid we can put a picture julius
herbie on the [ __ ] wall that's a fan
we're all friends we talk online we get
men on twitter we got no fans i don't
want nobody standing like a [ __ ]
moment like he's gonna suck my dick if i
got a neighbor no i don't need that [ __ ]
no it's and it's people do that all the
time and and the difference is like on
the plane if i was sitting on the plane
honestly i probably would have said it i
would have told my friends later and
what about it that they stink yeah no
you got to say something that's why god
gave you a [ __ ] mouth yeah that's why
god gave you a map i don't want this guy
to spread the stink on a different
[ __ ] flight why should they this
ain't fair just because you know they
all have their reasons well i don't like
wearing deodorant because the harms the
[ __ ] no no you know what harm is the
ultraviolet rays that stink that's
coming out of your armpit and the rest
of this thing that's coming out of your
[ __ ] ass that's what harms the
[ __ ] environment that you have to
wear [ __ ] deodorant you gotta put the
i don't want to smell nobody's stinky
around me deadheads are dead i don't
give a [ __ ] you have to take and even if
you don't take a shower you take a
puerto rican shower which i've taken at
an airport i was in the airport stuck
two days you take a bath in the sink you
ever take a bath in the [ __ ] puerto
rican style you do your hair you do your
balls you get a towel that's tough to do
that in san francisco there was a guy
that kept
in 85 i'm in san francisco and he was
like hanging out when i was a kid i went
to a porn theater one time okay but he's
like let's go out to like this queen
mary in jersey on a sunday night
and when you go to the bathroom a guy
always pops up and pisses next to you
you ever been in that situation now well
as you're pissing some guy will pop up
and start pissing next to you and look
at you and smile and then you leave and
you don't think none of it when you come
back to pee 20 minutes later the same
guy pops up to you
nobody could piss this much what they
are perverts they hang out in the
[ __ ] bathroom and they try to pick
you up in san francisco they had one of
those in 85 a guy that would pop next to
you and smile and make believe like hey
how are you are you flying where are you
going to tulsa get the [ __ ] out of you
professional
but then you know there was no psa in
those days no tsa nobody's patting you
down this you know these [ __ ]
perverts were on airports this is
airports in 85 i got stuck there like
you need to be people from san francisco
you know i'm not lying i'm not trying to
be funny i'm not trying to be hacked
it's a true story you know in 85 i was
staying at the uh virginian hotel now
it's the uh where people come from all
over the world hostile that's down in
the tenderloin they used to be the
virginian hotel and i would follow the
maid every day and steal her [ __ ]
keys and go into people's rooms that's
how dumb they're made
i put on a suit and go to the hilton
across the street
and [ __ ] follow the maids
and when they go in the room they leave
the keys in the [ __ ] door i just take
the key and take the the main key off
the ring and then just drop them on the
oh come on oh i was waiting
[ __ ] yeah i was the last of the real
deal dog in 85. nobody was running like
me but i was living at the virginia
hotel and i got the keys to the maiden
there was a guy that was taking action i
would rob him once a week you know i
just had that little keys and i would go
through that room and rob them here rob
them there stop every week oh i swear to
god one day i busted into a room and
there was german tourist [ __ ] german
[ __ ] those [ __ ] we run with the
jews
so uh
i go in that room and i'm looking for
[ __ ] i can't find on cause i see the
doors starting to [ __ ] open oh [ __ ] i
lock the door and i'm in there hiding
what am i gonna do i look at the balcony
on the second floor i can't jump on the
[ __ ] fledge off this [ __ ] ledge i
sit in the bathroom or something like we
call the police the police come i open
the door and they're like what are you
doing here dog i was trying to get
towels and i chased the maid and i came
in here and i talked to police and i
made up some story and they did a
background check and i really had
nothing at that time and they're like we
don't know what to do and the german
tourists were pissed but they didn't
arrest me
i knew they were coming back at that
time i was running [ __ ] scams and you
know and they have like a little asian
town up in there saying or the whole
[ __ ] town is
but they called it something it was by
van s like this asian cultural mall and
in those days travelers checks you can
just sign them everybody else ask you
for an id the asians don't give a [ __ ]
because traffic american express will
replace them anyway so i would go up
there and buy like a pack of lifesaver
for a dollar but give a 50 [ __ ] bill
uh travelers check
so something happened so they were
looking for me for the travelers checks
and then here i am trying to rob these
german [ __ ] tourists so i went to the
airport i had no money for a plane
ticket they caught me in between the
whole scam i had a girlfriend at the
time who ended up being
my daughter's mother i put her on the
flight first and i stayed like a man
what a mistake that was that dirty [ __ ]
i know she turned out to be a [ __ ]
dirty wall with a leftover in san
francisco but we went to reno first on
the bus came back went to san francisco
i had to wait two dollars for western
two days for western union
so i lived at the [ __ ] sfo for two
days oh [ __ ] shoplifting food and taking
showers at the [ __ ] thing and
walking around like i knew people you
know they didn't have tvs or computers
then when you were in an airport for two
days you were stuck [ __ ] you were deep
in thought you know what i'm saying
you're like [ __ ] should i just start
walking yeah that's like that's crazy i
couldn't imagine just living yeah
and no one would say i mean i gotta
there's people that are online nobody
knew nothing in those days it wasn't
like now that people watching you
couldn't go through gates remember the
other days i gotta walk you all the way
to your [ __ ] plane and hang out there
oh okay you know in the old days i'm
gonna walk you all the way to the
[ __ ] bottom so
yeah it's changed a lot man airports
you've never even you'll never see that
ever again you wish you were stuck you
could drive to a [ __ ] airport go in
there go up and sleep who's gonna say
something it's long-range parking
i don't know how many times we went to
an airport and just chilled for a day or
two really that's that's unbelievable
so what do we got lee what do you got
this week tonight we got a great game
atlanta denver oh that's and and you i
can't can't believe you didn't right now
you said denver is the giving points to
denver
yeah they give them two points number
three point in the however numbers 52.
so i'm staying away from this i don't
even [ __ ] with those things
honey and what else is going on this
week we got ufc
one [ __ ] 50 something i'm all
out of [ __ ] numbers who knows i know
it's belfor and [ __ ] jon jones fear
of a black planet you follow me oh yeah
that that someone made a video you put
you put up last night look it's like the
best of you 140 minutes it's 140 f-bombs
tremendous yeah
and whoever in like halfway through it
it's you doing fear of a black planet in
front of john joe oh [ __ ] you i don't
[ __ ] around
yeah
you got in fact give me a public enemy
to close out this [ __ ] hey guys
thank you very much for paying attention
thank you for listening to the church of
what's happening now to my main man lee
syed the flying [ __ ] jew i love him
there's another guy listen guys he's
been coming to me lately saying people
are following him on twitter this kid's
a [ __ ] sharp guy and i love with all
my heart i break his balls
yesterday i had to break the balls he
was talking about 250 000 louis ck
because we're thinking of doing a
special together he's going to tape it
but lee always wants to be like you know
johnny [ __ ] you know he wants to be
martin scorsese and we all we got is two
dollars yeah but you know he wants to
get cameras he's telling me cameraman
what [ __ ] cameraman you're you're the
cameraman yeah but there's a difference
between being martin scorsese and you
think we can just show up and go to best
buying in the camera and hey we're just
going to film this tonight this [ __ ]
guy is the only jew that thought that
buys retail i've never been a jew that
by retail you're the only [ __ ] guy i
say go buy a camera dog there's a
thousand dollars get on the phone you're
a jew that's what your people
that's what jews do this is the only
producer wants to pay top dollar for
everything oh it's 200 what 200 get on
the phone tell them your people you're
[ __ ] by your people
give him all the respect in the way he's
my little brother thanks man lisa lee i
love with all my heart i torment him i
[ __ ] love him he torments me i think
he [ __ ] with me through some time now a
little bit marilyn monroe i know because
he like these [ __ ] know i get
robbed up and they love to see it wait
till i have a heart attack
wait till i have a heart attack they're
gonna be like the [ __ ] guy on son's
anarchy they're gonna feel bad about it
and [ __ ] i actually i i thought it might
have been an old place i didn't know if
it was marilyn monroe but uh you wanted
us so we want to bring up we have enough
song intro so we're going to make it up
this week we're going to look at it and
decide we've got a bunch of great ones
thank you very much
and then also we uh this is going to
we're going to move to ustream we're
making the move
and uh within a week or two so keep
making make keep looking on joey's
twitter and and we're going to make a
move at some point
and that's it brother you never tell
about a movie you're going to make till
you tell the people [ __ ] momo see
you're [ __ ] up again you're trying to
tell the move we're going to surprise
you and put some stuff in the studios
and get some color in here but let me
tell you something guys
from the bottom of mind lee knows uh
when we started this podcast swear up
[ __ ] business this podcast was
started
just to have an extra voice that's it
once a week for you guys give you a
little bit more content we never dreamt
never [ __ ] dreamt this was not in our
dreams for even being the top 10
what you guys have done uh thank you
from the bottom release look at the
[ __ ] cameras thank you
that's a boy don't look at me look at
the camera
no it's unbelievable i mean i i knew
people would like it and like you but it
just no no no you guys uh you guys have
made our year from the cd
to the dvd to the love your show at the
shows i i can't even [ __ ] begin i
can't even begin i'm 50 years old and
you guys have uh you know
stuck a finger in my ass as they say i'm
saying to you uh where am i at this
weekly thursday i'm in madison wisconsin
at champs tickets on uh round paper
tickets and on friday i'm in germantown
in milwaukee my favorite plucking place
a shout out to my brother duke
[ __ ] rufus out there the movie
thai and all the boys he's got in this
[ __ ] camp i love duke i'm gonna try
to stop by and throw some side uh kicks
for jesus but friday night brown paper
tickets were in germantown ticket to 20
bucks it's myself and duncan
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] somebody emailed
me they're like twenty dollars joey for
dunk i said it's two of us at two
[ __ ] twenty four twenty dollars two
of us you can't go to remote you know
you go to a comedy club sometimes it's
twenty dollars just for [ __ ] me i
don't make the [ __ ] prices you know
but listen whatever you can do i'll
either see you thursday in madison or
friday in milwaukee you're right but
we're doing another uh church wednesday
yeah and we're doing a special
post
[ __ ] ufc
pre-nfl church of what's happening now
coming at you explosives we were going
to see if jesus shows up this week we
love you [ __ ] in the bottom
line thank you for listening to us every
week play a little go off me a little
public enemy what do you got done
you